ora questo video veramente strano non
l'ho mai fatto che mi fa molto strano
per rivedere dove abito e la prima volta
avete visto dei diverse volte pezzi di
casa mia perché durante gli capitava
specialmente prima del 2015 quindi prima
di trasferirmi a milano
capitava di vedermi in diverse location
perché magari regista vodese dell'equipe
però mai in un video solo tutte quante
quindi oggi mettiamo insieme i pezzi
della casa di famiglia è comunque un
giga puzzle
partiamo dalla porta di casa preso la
mia porta di casa bellissima e c'è anche
un cerbero di guardia il cane a tre
teste
vabbè una le altre si svilupperanno nel
tempo abbiamo il salotto fa vj tipico
salotto torinese with a great divano
questo divano aveva allora io amo i
divani a penisola quindi quelli che ci
hanno un pezzo in più infatti anche
quello mio a milano ad esempio questo
divano era un pelino più lungo solo che
abbiamo tolto dopo un tot di anni il
pezzettino in più perché apple si vede
gara ingombrante non ho idea questo è il
divano dove guardavo la televisione dove
non capitati di guardarla perché la fini
non accendo la tv che saranno da quando
sono andato a milano non più acceso la
tv penso che la sala sia sempre stato il
fulcro di una casa lo vedo come il
centro della casa come il cuore pulsante
di un appartamento e quindi la mia sala
mi è rimasta veramente nel cuore c'è
anche da dire una cosa in particolare
vedete questo arco molto strano che si
conclude con cui si fa reti qui ecco in
realtà quest'arco l'hanno fatto
esattamente quando sono andato via io
perché hanno rimodernato un po il
salotto perché una volta al divano era
qui è tutto questo mobile che ancora non
ho capito come si chiama
nella terminologia mobile del salotto
quello classico era dall'altra parte e
quindi casa mia non sarà mai più la
stessa perché io nei miei ricordi cielo
specchiata perché in realtà al divano
era dall'altra parte i muri non erano
così è molto diversa da come da quando
ci vivevo io inoltre da quando esiste
some abbiamo aggiunto dei pezzi
aggiuntivi di arredamento che sono
doverosi come mai non stai urlando
schizzando da una parte alla tornata di
solito ci sono muoiono in morbido
muovono questi ragazzi sono le foto di
quando ero piccolo se vedete quando c'è
questa poi è una foto in particolare vi
faccio vedere
avevo una voglia sulla guancia poi
vedete perché io ero piccolo sapete
quando si pizzicano le guance ai bambini
perché di fatto il problema è che io da
piccolo che lo facciamo da solo c'è io
da piccolo mi pizzica vole guancia
perché amo morbide giuro io mi pizzica
le guance datolo un deficiente quadri
aveva questo aspetto nega cassettone di
guerre stellari che non mi e mai garbato
guerre stellari non è mai piaciuto
regalo un so come mai stare funzione per
star wars pure mio padre è sempre andato
matto
strano perché tutto quello che piaceva a
mio padre in genere piaceva a me fatti
quando tutti mi dicono ma perché non ti
piace star wars io non so è che
rispondere perché vi giuro ho sempre
dovuto sto problema ultimo pezzo del
salotto e questo motivetto che
all'interno lo scoprirà anche tra poco
ci sono i miei vecchi libri che leggevo
e quando ero piccola tra l'altro fa
ridere perché qua c'è il tuo primo libro
della storia è il tuo primo libro della
terra è la cosa che fa veramente ridere
che li leggevo da bambino erano liberi
di quand'ero piccolo e che questo è
stato veramente il mio primo libro
quindi non è solo il titolo è anche così
davvero qui ragazzi forlì falasca noi
abbiamo finito la sala andiamo invece in
cucina la cucina è sempre rimasta
abbastanza la stessa se non che ci sono
foto mie che mi scacco
vicino al frigo io ho sempre avuto la
mania quella che hanno un po tutti alla
fine di attaccare sul frigo i vari posti
dove sono andato infatti vedeva
disneyland o ci ho fatto anche un blog
hollywood l'avete visto tutti i loghi di
hollywood
new york su san giovanni giani wing
radioso fondente per pasta sfilata
amsterdam insomma tutte le robe che qui
già magari avete visto appunto nei nei
blog ho preso delle calamite e lo
portate appunto ai miei genitori
comunque la cucina è questa abbiamo
anche la chicca ragazzi hanno
dimenticato ichat oakley favi james
andiamo a vedere il resto della casa
vediamo come vi faccio collegare con
tutte le altre stanze viene anche tu no
la madonna di dio la norma che buio che
va beh questo è il corridoio collega ad
altre cinque stanze della casa tra cui
la mia che si può capire che la mia
perché c'è scritto riservato loro rubato
da una panchina in una chiesa a questo
scritta non imita temi questa è
l'assenza di mio padre non mi faccio
subito vedere questa è la praticamente
cameretta del mi babbo come anche se
sembra la mia visto le robe sul culo
però mio babbo è molto orgoglioso quindi
si colleziona insomma le varie i vari
achievements questo è dell'album di
figurine
quello era di l'inter a picco ci sono i
miei tac e questi sono queste sono un
paio di fan art attaccateli lui si
teletrasporta la non in realtà non
cammina mio papà come potete vedere è
musicista ma questo penso si sia capito
come cacchio di della sua cose che
questo pianoforte in particolare lui
sono al piano è il suo main instruments
il piano gliel'ho regalato io circa
due anni fa se non erro e ho regalato io
ne va molto fiero perché insomma è un
master piano quando ero piccolo non
avevo il computer io di là quindi venivo
a giocare qua ad esempio a world of
warcraft a tutti i giochi che che mi
babbo aveva questo è warcraft iii uno
dei miei primi giochi dal quale poi ho
iniziato a giocata ma c'è il seriale
porca vacca censura jean pierre ha
censurato bravo gianpi che censura
questo è il mio bagno cioè mio è nota
hanno preso siamo un po tutti però è
quello di fianco a camera mi sa che è
questa quindi io teoricamente ho sempre
utilizzato questo che il bagno diciamo
più grosso di tutta la casa ha come
potete vedere non vi ho presentato il
sangue di questa stanza che qui comunque
questo è un bagno abbastanza spazioso se
ci pensate perché c'è anche la vasca da
bagno la vasca da bagno
ecco per me è un must la vasca da bagno
è sempre stato ma perché anche a milano
io faccio il bagno perché mi rilassano
serve è una cosa che mi ha sempre
lasciato anche da bambino quindi io
cerco sempre di avere la vasca da bagno
disponibile niente non avremo un bagno
che vedevo spiega in bagno e bagno cosa
fai esami del bagno andiamo ragazzi
invece a conoscere il sound del bagno
piccolo che e quest'altro avrà siamo
bagno piccolo signora il bagno piccolo
ciao come stai questo è il bagno e bagno
meno agibile però uno se deve far mai
agata veloce usa quello non credo ci sia
nulla da dire su questo bagno se non che
c'è la lavatrice
insomma il bagno quello meno
servizievole mancano due stanze
questa è la stanza dei miei genitori non
c è la stanza che forse ho frequentato
di meno in tutta la mia vita perché cosa
ci vado a fare altro tredicenne sempre
stanza dei miei genitori quello gliel'ho
preso io in giappone penso sia il
miglior pezzo d'arredamento di tutta la
casa e veramente figo e l'opera di
rubare niente che stava stanza team i
genitori c'è letto c'è l'armadio una
volta quando ero piccolo dormivo primi
genitori fino a un età abbastanza
avanzata in realtà tipo avevo 8 9 comico
col toro e non lo so ragazzi mica va
addosso che mi caga addosso quelle che
problema c'è faccio vedere la vista
perché c'è anche il balcone ma almeno
ora abbiamo messo a the national
apribile e questo l'ha vista di casa mia
ragazza ora quella è una fattoria si
sente sempre un sacco di puzza di
martedì di qua dopo un po ci fa il naso
e quindi non lo senti più questo qua
invece è il panorama
sono le sette di sera quindi anche un po
biglietto tra virgolette perché di
giorno è molto bello e uno spettacolo la
vista di casa mia
qua hammad caselli qua in piemonte
secondo me è imbattibile anche perché a
milano
ovviamente vedo solo palazzi da piccolo
giocavo con la pallina di spugna quella
era una porta mi babbo andava lì e
facevamo le le partite di calcio le
tante palle le tombolate giusto e credo
che sia in realtà tutto questo è il
posto a 360 gradi dove ho vissuto per
tutta la mia vita praticamente fino a
che non mi sono trasferito a milano
quindi ragazzi abbiamo finito e manca
soltanto ovviamente interhome number
wine che ovviamente
conoscete tutti o meglio per un bel po
di tempo avete conosciuto solo questa
visione della stanza
anche questo se ci pensate è cambiata
perché adesso i muri ton arancioni
quando ho iniziato a fare video se
guardate sul canale andate video meno
recenti e guardate i primi lasciate
stare
oddio che urlavo e la vide la
videocamera che era un amurt che non a
web cam il muro era giallo quindi io
all'inizio abbiamo proprio i muri
diversi somma è cambiata anche camera
mia nel corso del tempo infatti adesso è
un po difficile riconoscerla perché
appunto è diventato una sorta di
magazzino di robben niente ragazzi
questa è la rom tour
anzi loud tour di parigi vi saluto con
some che rovista tra la mia dai miei
viveri ci vediamo ad un prossimo visto
che fatemi sapere sì certo non era una
roba alla think linz questa però che vi
aspettate o casa mia
piemonte sono umile loro petecca nel
milano vicino
voglio bene sono comunque contento di
aver vissuto qua perché comunque il
piemonte in se non che il mio paesino si
chiama family casella mi ha regalato un
adolescenza e un'infanzia invidiabili
quindi io sono molto orgoglioso di
essere cresciuto qua egli essere intese
niente
[Musica]